autre nouvelle maintenant vous allez
voir le maire de laval alexandre
duplessis
la ville est sous tutelle mais il est
toujours maire de laval se retrouve dans
l'embarras encore une fois il a porté
plainte pour extorsion la sûreté du
québec contre deux escortes ont rejoint
émilie dubreuil alors ml racontez-nous
ce qui s'est passé où à une histoire peu
reluisante patrice pour le maire de la
valeur ce que l'on si ce que des sources
à l'intérieur de la sûreté du québec
nous ont appris c'est que le maire du
plessis avait réservé donc les services
d'une escorte qui est accompagné d'un
chauffeur une femme
et lorsqu'une lorsque l'escort l'a
reconnu elle lui dit ah vous êtes le
maire de laval
du plessis aura un peu paniqué et
renoncer aux services des deux femmes et
aurait aussi refusé du même coup de les
payer alors les deux femmes se sont
fâchés on exiger un paiement malgré
l'annulation est là c'est là que ça
s'est gâché du plessis s'est obstinée
avec elle et finalement lui ont demandé
2 3 fois d'être payés et lui a décidé
tout bonnement de porter plainte à la
sûreté du québec pour extorsion bon et
une enquête est en cours mais aucune
accusation était déposée contre les deux
femmes que la sûreté du québec un
intérêt dont vous utilisez vous avez
parlé à des gens la sûreté du québec
mais ça a été confirmé par son adjoint
qui est effectivement le maire de laval
a porté plainte donc pour extorsion ou
ipred auprès d'eux mais c'est tout ce
qui a été confirmé patrice la tentative
d'extorsion évidemment le reste de
l'histoire ce qui entoure cette
tentative d'extorsion là ce sont nos
sources à l'intérieur des forces
policières qui nous l'ont raconté ben
voilà suite demain merci décidera merci
au revoir merci